ترى الأسعار لن تكون
عند هذا الحد فقط لأنهم عندما
ينظرون إلى التوقعات
وكم ستكون الأسعار على مدى
العامين المقبلين وكل ذلك ولكن بالتأكيد
عندما ترتفع الأسعار
ستزيد من قيمة  الشركة
ليس هناك شك في أنه من المهم من وجهة نظرك
في هذه المرحلة من الوقت أن يتضمن الاكتتاب العام
إما إدراجًا في نيويورك أو
لندن من وجهة نظرك كرئيس تنفيذي هو
أن الأفضلية على الأقل
لدينا وجهات نظرنا الخاصة في جميع هذه الأسواق  لقد
أجرينا تقييمًا وألقينا نظرة على بورصة نيويورك ، حيث أجرينا أيضًا تقييمًا وتقديرًا
لبورصة لندن
وهونغ كونغ وبورصة طوكيو
وأعطينا
وجهات نظرنا ولكن القرار
في النهاية للمساهم الذي نراه  قائمة رئيسية في
السوق الغربية مع
طرح خاص وإدراج محلي
حيث نتجه إلى الثانية ،
لم يتحدث أحد عن
الطرح الخاص في هذه المرحلة ، ما قالوا إنه
سيتم إدراجه في  tada wall
وقمنا بتقييم الجيوب
المختلفة وهذا التقييم الذي تم إجراؤه
للمساهمين سيقرر
مكان الإدراج ولكن لم يتحدث أحد عن
الاكتتاب الخاص في هذه المرحلة
، اقترحت بورصة نيويورك
أنه لا ينبغي لنا الانحناء للخلف للوصول إلى منحدر
أي شخص آخر تتوقع منه
وضع أي نوع من القواعد الخاصة
لإدراجك بما في ذلك على سبيل المثال
مدفوعات الإتاوة التي تعد ميزة خاصة في
دول الشرق الأوسط بالطبع أنت
تعلم أنها تنحني للخلف ، فأنت بحاجة إلى
إخباري أولاً بما حدث لفترة طويلة
طلب اقتباس منك أولاً وقبل كل شيء ، لكن ما لدي من
ازدهار لم يكن يتوقع أن ينحني أي شخص إلى
الوراء بالنسبة لنا عندما ندرج ،
سيكون لدينا متطلبات معينة إذا كان
هذا القرار هو الاستماع إلى هذا
البلد أو ذلك البلد ، وبناءً على
ذلك ، سوف نتخذ  إذا كان هناك أي
متطلبات ولكننا لا نطلب من
أي شخص ، فهذه نهاية اليوم
يمكنك أن تقول نعم أو يمكنك أن تقول لا